aujourd hui
et
bonsoir et bienvenue sur diagonale
l'actualité internationale du jeu
d'échecs ce soir avec le grand maître
international et loire ou l'ain bonsoir
stéphane alors avant de toute chose
qu'on aborde le coeur de notre émission
aujourd'hui il doit tout à fait le
tournoi de montpellier et tu as fait un
super résultat et notamment un sprint
époustouflant d'après jean pierre
mercier de libération oui c'est vrai
j'étais partie assez assez mal en fait
avec trois points sur cinq ce qui était
donc un débuts médiocres mais en fait
sur le début j'avais beaucoup axé sur le
sport j'avais fait vraiment beaucoup de
sport pour être en forme sur la fin de
tournoi comme le tour des gnons dure
neuf jours c'est un vrai marathon et
donc pour les quatre dernières rondes
j'étais en super forme j'ai arrêté de
m'épuiser à faire du sport et j'ai donc
je me suis concentré uniquement sur le
jeu j'ai fini par 4 sur 4 en battant
christian bauer à la dernière donc un
super résultat voyez je partage la
première place avec trois autres joueurs
donc un et loire roland le bien
requinqué et tous remontés et ce soir et
demain le championnat de paris
donc tu as tu dors tu tiens titre
d'ailleurs champion de paris en titre
voyez des deux dernières années
voilà alors cette semaine les lois on en
était aux noces en deux parties juste
après d'ailleurs que tu rentres de mon
palin sont partis à dortmund voir le
super tournoi de cet été du mois de
juillet et on a passé je crois on a fait
un très très beau voyage la main oui
donc moi c'est la première fois que
j'allais voir un grand tournoi comme ça
sans participer disons simplement aux
touristes sans même pour jouer l'open à
côté j'ai été vraiment impressionnée par
par l'organisation
donc je pense qu'on va voir on va voir
des très belles images de ce tournoi
alors pour commencer justement on va
envoyer le petit clip l'ajustement qui
vous présente un petit peu le tournoi
l'ambiance un petit peu là bas un petit
clip qui dure environ deux minutes voilà
donc dès que c'est disponible
je comprends voilà on va l'envoyer voilà
petit clip sur dortmund
et g
à
voilà fin de ce petit clip plat de
présentation de danses contes et loi on
a vu la scène on a vu les joueurs
n'avaient karpov qui sait qu'on a vu on
a mis aussi kramnik qu'ils soient tous
les joueurs on a vu un avis peter l'écho
on a vu michael adams yvan sokolov
filiale timan enfin on a vu vraiment
tous les participants on a vu sur tous
les écrans de projection vidéo qui sont
vraiment le le très bel élément de ce
tournoi qui le transforme un show
vraiment accessible c'est toutes les
parties diffusées sur ces quatre écrans
que vous avez vu les quatre écrans jaune
dans le fond qui font vraiment en fait
qui rendent l'organisation remarquable
oui et en plus évidemment les
commentaires les commentaires qui font
le spectacle et on aura d'ailleurs à la
fin de notre reportage interview du
commentateur vedette labaki hellmuth
flyers qui ont commenté adam contre
depuis quelques années maintenant et qui
parle très bien français
oui en fait c'est ainsi un vieux routard
des commentaires et j'y tiens il parle
plusieurs langues il parle français
espagnol anglais et allemand et je me
rappelle à murcia en 91 ou 92 quand
j'étais à l'école garry kasparov c'est
déjà lui qui commentait le tournoi de la
gm a donc vraiment c'est comment docteur
comme un vecteur commun temps on verra
ça la fin d'émission ont accès
aujourd'hui notre émission sur la partie
notamment l'écho kramnik en fait mon a
surtout passé tout c'est tous ces
interviews qu'on a parce qu'on a des
interviews de deux concerts de plusieurs
de plusieurs joueurs et on va démarrer
tout de suite avec la première interview
ce soir de peter l'écho à une traîtrise
ou l'interview mais je vous laisse la
découvrir avec nous cette interview de
peter les cocons contentera juste après
des gones à l'actualité internationale
du fait des siennes aujourd'hui nous
sommes très lentement puisqu'on retrouve
karpov kramnik à nantes est évidemment
peter les coûts qui est avec nous
maintenant peter déco last week
du point de vue de tous
lost in july ou plus exactement
disposition
ok ok sont remis à sauter ok peter
l'écho maintenant on nous montre la
position critique qu'il a obtenue contre
la lumière cramique et donc il va nous
commenter la position la plus critique
de sa partie vous montrer les positions
que les possibilités qu'il avait dans
cette partie de petits composition des
familles capital economics
donc après cette nouveauté théorique de
peter l'écho le cavalier en d2 on va
arriver ensuite à une deuxième position
qui d'après peter déco et la position
critique de cette partie donc ça va être
très intéressant d'avoir l'avis du
numéro 10 mondial sur ses positions
malheureusement pour exemple blake 6-3
6-3
la fille de 6 ans de contrat donc ok va
donc voilà l'analyse brillante de peter
l'écossé position position critique on
aura sûrement l'occasion de voir plus en
détail cette partie de l'analyse et puis
de voir avec vous les possibilités que
peter l'écho nous a montré sur cette
partie sow
voilà donc l on a une super interview de
peter l'écho nous a analysé sa partie de
façon très brillante je crois qu'on va
pouvoir y revenir et on a vu avec quelle
facilité en tout cas il s'exprime après
une partie où il était éprouvons très
éprouvé mais c'est vrai qu'on a vu les
joueurs très fatigués après les parties
je pense notamment à nantes qui était
complètement en sueur après sa partie
contre karpov complètement épuisé il
aurait pratiquement plus bouger
alors que peter les corps lui
décontracté tout frais il arrive
provoc nickel et comment cette interview
avec beaucoup de facilité
commentant la partie assez clairement je
pense c'est alors qu'est ce qu'on va
regarder
voilà on doit revenir aujourd'hui donc
assez rapidement puisque on a encore
beaucoup d'interviews vous montrer sur
donc cette cette analyse de peter l'écho
on va donc venir sur la partie du jour
je vous rappelle que pour regarder cette
partie avec nous vous pouvez cliquer sur
la petite icône où il ya écrit joué sur
les missions qui vous fait rentrer sur
un petit applet java sur lequel nous
avons jeux téléchargés la partie donc
vous pourrez la suivre avec nous vous
avez aussi la possibilité de la
télécharger en fichiers pgn avec un
logiciel prévu pour ça prenez le temps
de découvrir dans la partie émission les
logiciels qui sont à votre disposition
voilà donc il doit on va venir
maintenant sur 7
donc sur cette partie et on va venir à
la position critique en fait que nous
analyse et peter les coûts pour traduire
un petit peu la rapidité avec laquelle
il nous a montré les variantes
oui oui donc bon la première chose qu'on
peut retenir de cette interview de peter
l'écho s'il a quand même dit que au
dernier tournoi francfort il a senti que
quelque chose lui était arrivé choses de
ce monde miraculeux et qui commençait à
jouer beaucoup beaucoup mieux mais c'est
ça qui est ça qui m'a troublé un peu
dans ce début d'interview donc peter
l'écossé était pressenti en forme
oui d'ailleurs à revenir après dans les
résultats du tournoi où est tout à fait
oui et donc voilà donc ça c'était pour
le début de l'interview mafieux on va
passer à la je crois qu'on peut même
dire que peter les coréennes des favoris
en tout cas à mon avis de las vegas de
las vegas ça n'engage ça n'engage que
toi
alors donc nous allons on va commencer
la partie on va s'arrêter aux premiers
moments critiques mentionné par peter
l'écho donc on va très vite aller sur le
coup donc c'est le sait après le coup
qu'à valider 2 après kelly des deux
voilà alors on va arriver à ce coup
voilà donc c'est le coup numéro 14 donc
je vous invite à avec votre appelé de
java où le logiciel sur lequel vous
regardez la partie de vous arrêter avec
nous sur le coup numéro 14
et on va avec éloi avec l'aide du grand
maître international et loire aux langes
b
essayez de voir les propos de peter
l'écho ce qu'il a dit dans cette
position alors pour l'instant dans cette
position précise il n'a pas dit grand
chose il a dit que le prix sont
critiques allaient arriver lundi quand
mais c'était une nouveauté théorique il
a dit c'est une nouveauté est que la
tâche des noirs étaient très difficiles
à gérer
voilà donc ça c'est vraiment important
donc il a cité comme étant le couple ce
qu'on appelle nouveautés où on va le
rappeler quand même hein c'est un cookie
d'un paravent pas été joués ou en tout
cas
inconnu des joueurs à ce niveau là de la
compétition
bon rythme mais alors là faut dire faut
préciser quand même que pour la plupart
des joueurs du top mondial
les nouveautés n'en sont plus vraiment
puisqu'ils ont tous découvert à peu près
les mêmes choses
ils sont tous en avance sur la théorie
actuelle des joueurs moyens bien sûr et
bien entendu donc mais quel est des deux
c'est ce qu'on appelle une grosse
nouveauté c'est à dire un coût qui n'a
pas été envisagé provenant par les
autres que peter l'écho est très content
d'avoir trouvé
donc quitte est ici nous a dit après
l'interview d'ailleurs que s'il avait
testé ce coup contre karpov ou n'importe
lequel des autres joueurs du tournoi à
part tarn et qu'il ressent doute gagné
assez facilement la partie
alors voyons pourquoi ce coût est si
intéressant que ça donc dont clermont le
cavalier partie de f3 en d2 sur cette
case là nous qui prépare une expansion
avec les pions ils contrôlent les cases
ici voilà l'idée peut être sexy les
blancs avaient cessé de pousser tout de
suite ce pion sur la case c4 le plan ces
trois là que tu te fais très en c4 donc
le vous là le fou aurait pu s'échanger
d'abord contre le cavalier est ce que ce
qu'empêche le coup de peter l'écho oui
oui tout à fait ça c'est une des
premières idées c'est que le cou c3 c4
ne marchait pas aux coups d'abord à
cause de fou preuve trois une raisons
tactiques simple élection des quatre
auraient été en prise maintenant donc
l'idée positionnelle de secousses et que
vous voyez que les deux pions en c3 et
des quatre contrôles très bien les cases
doit enfin en l'occurrence les classes
vertes sur l'échiquier que vous avez
devant vous alors que ce coup cavaliers
des deux va contrôler les cases blanches
qui sont ici les cases jaune
donc ça fait une très belle harmonie en
fait entre les pions et les pièces c'est
l'idée positionnelle de secousses et sa
élit des tactiques c'est l'expansion des
pions rapide donc voilà pour expliquer
un peu cette nouveauté
alors on va passer maintenant sur la
position critique dans ce n'est par
peter l'écho donc après cavaliers en a
cinq
celui de fou détroit le groupe b 6 la
petite heure l'écho mais saddam en
batterie avec le fou à dakar le pian
près du roi mena
en foot prend un échec donc kramnik le
protège et ensuite le couffo b2 le fou
de kramnik ensuite revient sur la case
bessette et le coup cavalier e 4 et
voilà si la position a été mentionné
comme comme très critique par peter
l'écho avec un coup mauvais à jouer côté
noir qui est le concept c 5e chronique
n'a pas joué voilà donc si tu peux voir
si on peut montrer loi donc son coût
possible
alors le coup ces cinq donc on va
montrer la variante sur l'échiquier donc
le crous et 5 voilà alors ici la vente
mentionné par peter l'écho je vais vous
la donne et on va pouvoir la regarder la
commenter ensemble
c'est donc dépensé 5 des français 5 c 4
alors maintenant ce qu'on voit c'est que
le four b2 qui est ici se réveille sa
diagonale vient de s'ouvrir et le fou va
taper directement jusqu'en g7 et on peut
noter que la deuxième fois est aussi
braquer aussi sur le roi voilà avec le
cavalier et n'est pas moins bien placé
toutes les pièces blanches sont vraiment
axé vers le roi vers le roi noir les
lecavalier le fou tout est là donc ici
position assez critique pour les noirs
alors il ya un point faible dans la
position blanche c'est la case que je
vais vous prie de faire clignoter ici la
case des quatre donc sur la proposition
donc de peter l'écho qui est kamel et c6
et une réfutation fracassante qui tient
du miracle et l'âge le site avec la
vente suivante [ __ ] angers7
donc super sacrifice de pièces a priori
on se dit dans une pièce mais on démolit
un peu le rock adverse
voilà c'est on a donné le coup j'ai sept
normalement il ya des justifications
techniques qui viennent tout de suite
dont 3 projets 7 et la dame b 2 échecs
donc bon la variante commence déjà à
durer quelques coups mais les joueurs
avaient
et tous les deux vu ça non je crois
qu'il a dit que crâne il n'avait pas vu
cette variante mais qu'ils avaient senti
que intuitivement
cette vente était dangereuse oui ça
lassant de voir tous les coups alors
qu'évidemment peter la connaissez bien
puisque c'était sa préparation sert
l'autre secrète on faire votre secret de
sa botte secrète du vnv deux échecs on
poursuit la variante 3 j'évite le
fouquet cette emprise donc les blancs
viennent le pont d'un premier set et les
noirs prennent également le fou des
toits donc ça fait un peu supermarché
chacun se sert non non le paquet de
pièces restantes à l'autre les blanches
ou dom français 6 et finissent avec un
pion plus le roi noir est complètement
détruit la perte du sens que j'ai 7 ici
avec il ya des échecs en perspective par
tous notamment sur la colonne j'ai donc
envoie un roi non roi qui seraient
sujets après une attaque dévastatrice ah
oui on est tout à fait donc ici si on
doit faire un bilan
la position est complète ni perdante
côté noir voilà donc c'est ce qu'avait
fédéral et la variante d'hôpital échos
qui quand même et donc il a vu au 19e
coup ça dure jusqu'au 24e avec d'autres
mis comme ça fait quand même une
profondeur de 10 coups ouais ça n'est
pas ce qui n'est pas négligeable alors
on revient à la partie donc ici crown
vic n'a pas joué c'est 5 il a joué b5 et
que peter l'écho et sting comme un conte
brillant un coût tout à fait brillant et
oui des cinq défense brillante c'est ce
que j'ai noté un c'est vrai que ce qui
était assez agréable dans ce cas et
peter l'écossé quand même que kramnik
n'a pas vu ses 5
il l'a reconnu il avait senti c'est
vraiment le feeling joue un rôle majeur
aux échecs quand ça vient trop compliqué
à calculer on calcule pas et on se
laisse aller à l'intuition
donc c'est là où on finit donc cette
petite analyse de partie voyez après b5
on peut regarder la suite de la partie
mais peter les cônes a mentionné que ça
n'avait pas un gros intérêt il a été
obligé de se satisfaire de la nulle
après des échanges multiples voilà donc
on vous invite à regarder ensuite la fin
de cette partie vous rendre compte que
la partie nulle a été obligé d'être
d'être scellé entre les deux joueurs est
donc on va arrêter là notre analyse de
ce jour puisque nous avons encore
beaucoup d'interviews à vous montrer que
le temps presse qu'elles sont elles ne
sont pas moins intéressantes a commencé
dès hier d'ailleurs par la partie civile
à l'interview suivante 2
numéro deux mondial encore une forme
lundi au téléphone elle aura déjà mais
cette fois on l'a en réel à dortmund il
a accepté donc de se faire interviewer
ont interviewé dans la salle de presse
du temps il a encore une très bonne
disponibilité d'un homme qui était plus
frais c'était le deuxième jour le
premier jour était très fatiguée mais la
deuxième jour c'étaient plus donc y
jouer contre michael adams
il était plus relax en fait voilà donc
on vous passe tout de suite dès qu on
peut décaler cette interview devise
manhattan en inde
au choix
le chiffre 2010
non
voilà donc interview du numéro deux
mondial visait à l'internât l'inde avec
là encore une fois une analyse de sa
partie contre cette fois michael adams
ou y analyse assez assez amusante dans
la mesure où tous les commentaires qu'il
a mentionné ont échappé à tout le commun
des joueurs et moi j'avais vu entrevue
aucune variante qui la proposait donc
hellmuth plerguer non plus et je pense
que les gens dans kirby complet donc
vraiment il ya quand même des ventes qui
dépassent la majorité des mèches ya même
des spécialistes chiliens
oui mais oui mais bon c'est vrai que
quand même numéro deux mondial
bon ça vous convient alors il nous a
donné aussi des informations mais enfin
des semis information intéressante
puisqu'on a parlé de son probable
championnat du monde contre garry
kasparov donc à la rentrée
donc il nous a juste annoncé que pendant
qu'il faisait le tour du monde il
n'avait pas de nouvelles supplémentaires
si ce n'est quand même que le contrat
effectivement été signé oui c'est ça il
a signé le contrat ils ont savent pas
plus sur la ville la ville où ça aura
lieu pour l'instant si prague qui est
pressenti mais là non nous a pas nous a
pas ni confirmer ni infirmer 5 ce qui
prouve que rien n'est sûr en tout cas à
part que le match aura lieu à part que
le match aura lieu tout à fait en tout
cas qu'il a signé donc voilà pour cette
donc cette interview devise manhattan
anand mais tout de suite après on a
rencontré sur l'adversaire du jour en
fait il doit nous avons rencontré
michael adams qui fait un petit tour
dans la cabine de commentaire comme tous
les joueurs le font ce qui est de bon
usage
il a été même un peu mentionné pour le
public de dortmund ses impressions pour
la partie il est revenu nous voir tout
de suite après donc voilà ce que ce que
ça donne pas ce que ça donne michael
adams sur taïwan le poste de dortmund
avec michael glos michael c
côté multi positions
voilà elle voit une interview au
sympathique des numéros anglais est
finalement un macadam
c'est le plus fort jolis moments et
numéro six mondial je prends oui oui non
mais tu hurles adamson a fait ses
preuves
depuis longtemps il est numéro un
anglais il a dépassé nigel short assez
facilement et là il est au top
actuellement nous lisez donc il compte
d'ailleurs compte tous les journaux à
taulé part dans tous les joueurs de
dortmund qui l'adorent en fait j'adore
cette ville je crois qu'ils aiment bien
revenir chaque année quand ils ont évité
parce que c'est pas toujours le cas
évidemment mais c'est un tournoi
vraiment que les joueurs aiment bien
jouer quoi c'est une constante chez tous
les joueurs
j'ai été assez surpris de assez surpris
de voir ça ils étaient tous vraiment
satisfait des conditions qui sont
offertes à dortmund ici il faut dire que
c'est à dire qu'elle vide est quand même
assez sympathique à gérer en nature ont
noté le vérifier ou même beaucoup de
fêtes en tout cas pour lehman et donc ma
que la deuxième visite sur sous trois
détenus qui avaient bien démarré contre
vannes en fait il n'a pas voulu avec
nous analysé deux parties parce qu'il a
jugée sur ses deux premières parties à
dortmund qu' aucune ne méritait un
intérêt particulier
oui oui c'est vrai sa victoire contre
yann timan tient plus de la bavure du
joueur hollandais que que de son que
l'efficacité de son style on peut dire
quant à la deuxième et avec les blancs
il s'est retrouvé assez mal dès le début
anne andreu qui jouait pour le guen n'a
pas n'a pas persisté vraiment donc en
fait dans aucune des deux parties il a
été en mesure d'imposer son jeu
d'imposer son style il a plutôt subi les
fautes ou loue les qualités de ses
adversaires maintenant qu'est ce qu'on
peut dire voilà internet de las vegas il
a parlé de las vegas
c est donc ce qu'il a dit sur las vegas
qu'il faut rappeler quand tu le disais
l'interview exclusive en est loin
je le rappelle quand même qu'il était
finaliste l'année dernière donc du
championnat du monde contre un dans
l'esprit antoine andré web et enfin le
finaliste pour le challenger de karpov
voilà ce qui était tout à fait
remarquable alors donc adams avec son
style très calme a dit le plus longtemps
on tient le mieux ce sera c'est il
s'avance pas trop quand même michael
adams steam calme dans le discours mais
pas sur l'échiquier
oui c'est très impressionnant de voir
comment un joueur aussi timide réservé
peut arriver dans les meilleurs
placements du mondial finalement autant
kasparov ça se comprend parce qu'on sent
le tigre prêt à bondir annonçant quand
même qu'il est très très vif très rapide
adams moi je ne sens rien quand je le
vois et pourtant il est très très fort
et on peut saluer ce joueur alors on
peut dernières informations concernant
michael adams qui te concerne aussi
l'année prochaine vous allez jouer dans
le même club
oui on va tous les deux je croque notes
ii de monaco on s'exporte
mais on reste quand même en france dans
le championnat national français donc tu
vas pouvoir côtoyer michael adams comme
tu as pu côtoyer d'autres annoncent
d'ailleurs qui joue également à monaco
enfin on a licencié je crois que karpov
et peut-être également une sorcière
monaco enfin à monaco c'est vraiment
celle à la formule 1 d
des clubs français c'est dire donc et
avec et laurent lange voilà donc on va
passer une interview un peu un peu
particulière ensuite puisque c'est c'est
un joueur c'est une joueuse en fait ce
n'est pas un c'est une joueuse mais qui
ne fait pas qu'ils ne jouaient pas dans
le disons dans le master's de dortmund
mais il y avait un tournoi à côté de
grands maîtres aussi avec donc un peu
plus de joueurs puisque le masters
c'était donc huit joueurs
alors que le tournoi 6 8 ou 10
l'aster ses bijoux et 7 et 8 juin et
alors que le tournoi de grands maîtres à
côté que compte tenu du joueur aussi
j'étais vite au salon s'était dit c'est
un peu plus voilà huit joueurs et puis
d'un niveau un peu moins élevé mais
c'est quand même une des meilleures
joueuses du monde puisqu'il s'agit de
lisa marie tx peut-être tu peux nous
leur présenter un petit peu oui allez ça
m'arrive c'est une joueuse yougoslave
qui a été entraînée par todorovic
miodrag todorovic à l'époque où il
habitait en france qui était également
mon entraîneur et donc elle a une soeur
qui s'appelle marianne a marriage qui
joue également très bien aux échecs
c'est donc la famille cette famille en
fait les échecs sont une tradition
familiale au niveau de sa vie elle a été
candidate au titre mondial en 91 ce
qu'elle va nous commenter assez
longuement est ce qu'on va pouvoir voir
tout de suite voilà donc tout de suite à
une interview d'une des meilleures
joueuses du monde je crois qu'elle est
10e mondial au classement féminin à lisa
maric
nous sommes encore dans la salle de
presse avec ali slama richie du match
biesheim obtenir ou non du platine
dortmund en nous épargnant plane samyn
m
voilà c'est une interview de lisa-marie
sur le 10e joueuse mondiale alors il
doit elle nous raconte et donc son match
contre contre auxilio donc et aussi sa
carrière un peu échiquéenne en disant
qu'elle faisait à la fois des échecs et
continuer en même temps c'est une wii en
fait elle a eu et la préparent donc au
match historique
il était donc le 14ème championnat du
monde d'échecs ou le challenger n'était
pas russe c'était un match entre elles
et sillonne donc une grosse perf contre
une chinoise et il se trouve que donc
elle a perdu ce match eq sillonné
devenue championne du monde en battant
magnachip organisée au match suivant
donc match historique pour commencer sa
carrière
sinon tu disais qu elle fait également
des études n'est pas jouer ce
professionnel a fait des études
d'économie elle expliqué que c'était
très très dur de vivre des échecs en
tout cas au niveau des échecs féminin
oui parce que enfin disons qu'il ya très
peu de tournois féminins qui s'organise
et donc il faudrait se hisser dix ans au
niveau des meilleurs joueurs humains un
homme je sais que je vais dire est qu'il
ya un petit gars très peu de femmes en
fait à ce niveau là y avait uniquement
fait judit polgar vih judit polgar
également que si youn qui vit très bien
du jeu dans la mesure où il ya tout le
pays qui est derrière elle puisque les
chinois c'est donc c'est vraiment
l'emblème l'emblème du pays donc il ya
toute une équipe qui la soutient elle
dispose de moyens énormes alors
qu'eux-mêmes souza pôle gare qui est
quand même une très très bonne chose qui
est donc qu'on le rappelle la grande
soeur de la famille polgar elle
ne se consacre pas à plein temps au jeu
d'échecs je reprends même ouvert un
magasin à new york sur les échecs le
pôle gare center à new york
les produits dérivés voilà les produits
dérivés des échecs c'est plus du
commerce à 10 ans voilà donc cédé des
revues donc de la lisa marie tch on va
passer maintenant à une interview d'un
grand monsieur des échecs
le vétéran du tournoi je pense donc
qu'il est un team and key qui joue
depuis très très longtemps qui a été
finaliste des candidats contre karpov en
si je me trompe pas non 95,5 oui enfin
le nom en 95 il a joué le match quand
kasparov et partie disons jouer son
match de championnat du monde contre
nigel short
ils ont donc organisé en finale
officielle disons de la fédération
internationale entre yann timani liliane
hôtelier karpov oui tout à fait donc
enfin dit opteaman de toute façon ça
fait très longtemps qu'il est dans le
circuit
c'est un maître dans l'art de l'analyse
il le son livre l'analyse aux échecs
s'est vendu fin a été acclamé par tout
là toute la presse et chicken tous les
joueurs d'échecs
c'est vraiment le plus bel ouvrage haut
niveau a analysé chicken qui ait jamais
été écrit alors on peut rappeler aussi
pour le public français
goldman a gagné le trophée bompard il me
semble c'est être au film part au grand
prix intel je crois c'est être au film
au parent il avait battu kasparov en
finale ils ont en fait c'était mémorable
donc ils avaient l'année suivante il
s'était fait battre justement par judit
polgar au premier tour en fait mais il
avait gagné là je crois que la salle
était debout pendant dix minutes et
c'était vraiment peut-être son plus bel
exploit
à part cette finale contre évidemment
anatoli karpov le fait d'accéder à cette
finale voilà donc yann timan tout de
suite sur des gonades
des gones à l'international bonjour nous
sommes aujourd'hui notre dernier jour
aussi de présence à dortmund et je
rencontre aujourd'hui un des tout
meilleurs joueurs du monde il s'agit de
yann team am timan qui a été finaliste
du championnat du monde contre anatoli
karpov en 1995 so'oialo wyeth
les cars postaux
ok la notion d'actif d'accord voilà donc
c'est une interview de yann timan donc à
dortmund
alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut noter les
lois sur cette interview si on peut
résumer un petit peu et bien ce qu est
ce qu on peut résumer c'est que viennent
timan pense qu'il joue bien mais il fait
des gaffes actuellement ce qui est une
en fait ce qui est tout à fait normal il
ne peut plus avoir autant l'afrique je
dirais que dans les années où il était
encore jeune et tout sportif donc il y
subit un peu l'épreuve du temps mais par
contre ça reste toujours un très bon
joueur qui donc apparemment est
satisfait de la qualité de ces partis
voilà donc et il a donc il a
il a parlé de sa première partie contre
adams où il a donc fait effectivement
une gaffe une erreur une gaffe
alors qu'il était une position même un
moment donné mais probablement meilleur
pour lui en fait oui tout à fait une
question légèrement favorable j'en avais
parlé à michael adams donc à dortmund
il m'avait expliqué qu'il n'avait pas
encore senti que le danger était
critique mais que ça pouvait devenir
assez difficile à défendre mais que
globalement il pensait quand même qu'ils
pouvaient faire nul à peu près par un
jeu disons un jeu solide et est bien
appliquée vous pouvez tenir le nul à
tout moment il n'a pas senti que la
police y ont dépassé un seuil critique
cependant donc effectivement timan et ai
été un peu mieux et a fait une grosse
gaffe qu'il a coûté un pion et la partie
voilà on a noté aussi que donc on l'a
rappelé dans cette interview qu'il ya un
team année le rédacteur en chef d'une
des plus fameuses revues et chicken
romande qui est une pièce nue michels we
will la revue de référence tous les gros
tournois sont traités là bas il y a des
très bonne analyse notamment diane timan
enfin tous les champions commandes garry
kasparov commente alexei shirov peter
l'écho krainik tout le monde commente
les partis là-bas et d'un team and
effectué toutes les semaines un travail
analytique importants sur des milieux de
jeu qui sont pas très étudié donc le
seul vidéo deux parties soient des
finales tout cas des compartiments du
jeu qui sont un peu délaissé par par les
ouvrages classiques aux échecs et donc
c'est apparemment c'est ce qui plaît ce
vétéran du jeu c'est le travail
analytique
dans tous les domaines du jeu voilà donc
une interview aujourd'hui de yann timan
sur des gones alors pour finir et loire
on a choisi une interview qu'on a pu
faire de du commentateur vedette en fait
de dortmund qui est donc hellmuth flyers
et qui donc on l'a dit au départ à une
super pêche et qui parle n n langue avec
haine assez grand et tout à fait un
nouveau fire très très polyvalent et
comment très très bien ça fait très
longtemps qui commentent et d'ailleurs
il va commenter pour nous tout de suite
de suite cela one à la limite rigueur
commentateurs adorent contre le
commentateur du tournoi de dortmund
celui qui donne les commentaires pour le
public qui vient nombreux dans le
théâtre voir les matches il s'agit de el
mout flickr qui déjà commentateurs ici
depuis plusieurs années alors elle monte
donc suivi ces deux premières journées
de compétition
quel est votre avis général sur la
qualité du tournoi
c'est vraiment une très bonne qualité
à mon avis et il ya beaucoup de luttes
il n'y a pas d'aidés des mules la fuite
mais vraiment et le jouer jusqu'au pain
il veut gagner et c'est très bon il y
avait déjà quelques bons exemples
comment éviter les co a gagné ses
émotions non
comment il était attaqué avec son
poignard ou osi la partie les amis
intimes année sur l'horizon des tris
dresse bon ami et un ensemble mais dans
dans les tableaux des chèques alors il
comme des com dès lors les voix des
déçus
il a fait dans tous les tableaux
jusqu'à des droits et alors andré tour
et donc on ne savait pas qui va gagner
qui va à terme à thonon c'était vraiment
très émotionnelle pour tout les
expectatives mais aussi pour les
commentaires pour les commentateurs
s'accordent donc après avoir donc c'est
très belle partie quel est votre
sentiment après ces deux premiers jours
au quai sont les joueurs qui sont a
priori les mieux placés pour remporter
ce tournoi
bien sûr normalement g n'est gagné
quatre fois consécutivement ici alors
vraiment élégant favoritisme mais aussi
est bichonné sait cela mais dernière
chance avant son match avec aspar alors
ils ce sont des grands favoris mais à la
voix anna cabana tous les cas pour jouer
très bien ici epeat à l'écossé il est
l'ami d'ici 17 villes allemandes déjà
avec france en est en
il est venu ici et tout le monde même si
beaucoup en allemand il avait même qu'on
traite avec un sponsor qui est ici et
espère que fait l écho il est leur forme
des documents tant qu'elle respecte va
gagner et ils ont très bonne chance et
mais aussi mal gré de céder dans le
dernier temps je vais mieux aussi
alors c'est vraiment c'est impossible
après one qui va gagner au fond alors on
peut noter une dernière chose ce tournoi
se déroule donc dans un très beau
théâtre à dortmund
il ya beaucoup de monde qui vient voir
les parties c'est une habitude qui
augmente chaque année il ya de plus en
plus de monde qui vient voir les le
grand tournoi de dortmund chaque année
non on ne peut pas dire
si chaque chat mais une fois il était
jusqu'en 2000 spectateurs dans le
théâtre et 50 maisons d'hôtes alors
vraiment c'est très bon et les facilités
à mon avis sont très bonnes avec vous
avez ça alors vraiment s'y intéresser
une grande tradition maintenant pour la
27e fois déjà et là c'est vraiment un
des deux qui avec cette tradition
congrès estime sergueï que nous avons
merci et voilà donc cette interview
c'est la dernière interview de la
journée donc du commentateur vedette et
loi qui en tout cas fait partager
absolument la passion des échecs ça
c'est ça me paraît clair oui on a pu le
voir dans son commentaire rapide de la
partie sokolov contre adams dans ce
colloque timone où il était là elle
partagée on avait l'impression qu'il
allait s'écrouler
lui-même se laissant prendre au jeu du
roi du roi pseudo call of qui est monté
de gmi tomber 3 vraiment
un joueur qui sait partager en tout cas
ses émotions tout à fait alors peut-être
on peut faire un petit bilan hier soir
en fait sur les partis qui se déroule à
dortmund sachant que ça se termine
samedi
donc demain en fait domaines thomas
terminé donc le le classement et on s'y
trompe pas on a vu qu'on a vu que le
celui qui avait l'air d'avoir le plus la
pêche était peter l'écho et bien il
semblerait que ça se confirme
peter les coups en tête du tournoi hier
soir avec quatre points oui oui mais
peter les cours l'enfant du pays en fait
comme comme on l'appelle là-bas c'est
vrai il est venu à dortmund quand il
avait 11 ans il parle très bien le mans
il est sponsorisé par une société de
dortmund donc tout le monde là-bas le
connais il est vraiment sur son terrain
en fait quand il joue à dortmund et donc
c'est un peu comme au foot le public
finit par jouer comme au tennis on a vu
tout à l'heure
evènement d'ailleurs sébastien grosjean
a perdu en coupe davis
enfin bon mais le public joue quand même
et donc cuites haricots se trouve
vraiment bonnes conditions à dortmund
est ici les en tête du tournoi je trouve
ça je trouve ça très bien voilà les
coûts qui a battu
donc
sokolov non topalov et timan mais aussi
les intimes
en deuxième position on retrouve
vladimir kramnik avec trois points et
demi est suivi par anatoli karpov et
vise manhattan avec trois points mais en
fait ils n'ont ne sont pas ils vont pas
perdre une partie mais ils ont fait
beaucoup de nuls en fait pour vidéo avec
non la surprise vient effectivement
critères l'écho travnik on l'attend
toujours là à dortmund puisqu'on l'a vu
dans une interview je crois que c'est
peter l'écho qui est mentionné que rami
qui était à 54 parties à dortmund sans
défaite donc sur une série quand même
assez impressionnante et surtout sur
trois victoires consécutives
il a gagné les trois dernières éditions
de dortmund donc c'est un peu l'homme du
tournoi est ici donc ramené en embuscade
en fait je dirais un nid points derrière
les co alors que hollande et karpov vont
faire une performance qui n'est pas
mauvaise mais qui n'est pas exceptionnel
non plus voilà donc suivre après michael
adams veselin topalov il va sokolow et
yann timan qui hier soir n'avait réussi
à arracher que pour l'instant qu'une
seule partie d'une balle en méforme et
yann oui tout à fait gentiment grosse
méforme sa partie nulle c'est la
deuxième ronde
là on est la sixième ronde ça lui fait
donc une série de trois défaites
consécutives ce qui est quand même assez
dur dur à encaisser bon maintenant on va
il a plus qu'une ronde pour te faire
lire est donc le tournoi est déjà passé
donc c'est assez c'est assez difficile
me faut dire quand même quand on joue
contre des jaunes qui s'acharnent qui
veulent marquer un point contre donc
contredire timan en l'occurrence c'est
un état d'esprit qui est assez difficile
à supporter alors voilà pour dortmund je
crois on a fait bien le tour j'espère
que vous avez apprécié toutes ses
interviews
l'actualité continue et demain démarre
en france un très très grand tournoi
puisque c'est le championnat de paris
avec un général près de 1000 joueurs wii
wheel chapelet de paris c'est le plus
grand tournoi open en france très
clairement avec 800 à 900 joueurs et qui
a été je crois même le plus grandes
peines du monde à un moment donné je
crois oui alors réagi en record il ya
les superproductions américaines qui qui
concurrence de près comme philadelphie
et new york ils ont tous autour de 800
joueurs ce qui est quand même
remarquable de vue que le tournoi dure
quand même dix jours il faut regrouper
800 joueurs pendant dix jours
c'est pas une chose facile le
championnat paris arrive maintenant la
qualité donc de ce tournoi n'est pas
forcément au rendez vous on trouve à peu
près une vingtaine de grands maîtres sur
huit joueurs moi c'est quand même ça
fait faut rappeler qu'il ya que 300 g n
dans le monde à peu près en activité on
peut en retrouver vers un endroit c'est
quand même bien oui enfin ces mots si on
compare par exemple à cappelle-la-grande
qui est plus limité avec 600 650 joueurs
où il ya quand même plus de 130 m oui
c'est vrai enfin faut aussi une fois de
plus la france met en bonne position
cappelle-la-grande et vendent le plus
fort européenne du monde alors pour les
gens qui nous écoutent qui sont à paris
ou dans les environs on va rappeler le
lieu c'est le chapelain de paris a lieu
à la halle carpentier
donc c'est à peu près de la porte de
choisy voilà donc station de métro porte
de choisy la halle carpentier vous
pouvez pas rater c'est un dingue brésil
maman voilà dans le xiiie arrondissement
donc avec et loire ou l'ain avec et
loire lange et loire où l'ange qui revêt
s'inquiétent range e titre de champion
de paris titre de champion de paris en
tout cas ravi et donc les parties ont
lieu à 17h en 19 heures en semaine c'est
fait pour ces faits le soir pour prendre
un maximum de gens y compris ceux qui
travaillent et le week end on joue à
quatorze donc vous tout le monde est
bienvenu
dans le temps voilà et d'agaune halle
sera présent à se sont plaints de paris
prenant quelques images et peut-être
quelques interviews
nous verrons voilà donc je vous dis à la
semaine prochaine si vous avez apprécié
n'hésitez pas à nous envoyer vos
commentaires et donc à vendredi prochain
on